IT'S TIME FOR OUR NEXT GAME,
"SERIAL KILLER OR OKCUPID
PROFILE?"
CANADIAN SERIAL KILLER
LUKA MAGNOTTA--"I'M GOING TO BE
KILLING YOU NOW"--
RECENTLY SET UP A DATING PROFILE
ON A SITE TO CONNECT CANADIAN
CONVICTS WITH SAD WOMEN WHO
PROBABLY FANTASIZE ABOUT GETTING
(BLEEP) BY THE NEW HAMBURGLAR.
>> IS THAT THE NEW HAMBURGLAR?
>> CHRIS: THAT'S THE NEW
HAMBURGLAR.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> CHRIS: YES IT IS.
HE'S GOING TO STEAL YOUR BURGER
AND ( BLEEP ) IT.
WOMEN OFTEN JOKE ABOUT MEETING
GUYS ONLINE BY SAYING, "HOW DO I
KNOW IF HE'S A SERIAL KILLER?"
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION, AND WE
HERE AT "@MIDNIGHT" WANT TO
HELP.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU THE NICKNAME
OF A REAL DANGEROUS
MULTI-MURDERER AND THE PROFILE
OF SOMEONE WHO IS HOPEFULLY
HARMLESS ON OKCUPID, AND FOR 250
POINTS, YOU HAVE TO TELL ME
WHICH ONE IS JUST A GUY ON A
DATING SITE AND NOT A
PSYCHOPATHIC MONSTER.
CASE IN POINT: WHICH ONE IS A
HARMLESS OKCUPID USER?
>> DEFINITELY LOVING GRAMA.
>> CHRIS: LET'S FIND OUT.
LOVING GRAMA, LET'S PULL UP
HER PHOTO AND SEE--
JESUS CHRIST!
>> I DIDN'T KNOW MY MOM WAS ON
THE INTERNET.
>> CHRIS: I'M SURPRISED SHE'S
NOT BUSY BREAKING JAMES CAAN'S
ANKLES IN A CABIN.
>> WHO'S THE PERSON LYING ON
THE BED THAT WENT, "I GOTTA GET
A PHOTO OF THIS."
>> HARMLESS OKCUPID USER:
LADY KILLER OR GIRL KILLER?
JIM.
>> GIRL KILLER.
>> CHRIS: LET'S FIND OUT.
GIRL KILLER?
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
ALSO HIS PROFILE SAYS, "MESSAGE
ME IF YOU LIKE
NAZIS AND THE OCCULT AND
SPIRITUAL AWAKENING, OR IF YOU
LIKE COFFEE, PIZZA, AND CHILLING
OUT."
>> THAT'S OKAY.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT'S REALLY BAD
ABOUT THAT?
WHO HAS COFFEE WITH PIZZA?
>> CHRIS: WHAT A MONSTER!
WHAT A MONSTER.
>> I WOULD MESSAGE THAT GUY BUT
I DON'T LIKE COFFEE, PIZZA, AND
CHILLING OUT.